welcome to this video this is round
seven yes seven of the gushy moth
memorial tournament played in shanky
Azerbaijan let's get going and I'm going
to use the new on sorting order but this
time alphabetical reversed so yeah
siding with vishay lagrave and going to
end with Rishi Anand let's get going
there and we got d for opening I a
transposition here mdl against Giri
let's see the Rogozin yeah very popular
opening it yeah it's quite surprising
how often this is played it seems to be
in a very good theoretical state at the
moment it is a mixture of the Queens
gambit declined and the new so in a way
and yeah what it does and I am
considering to take that up as well I
have played this opening actually in the
90s but pretty much forgotten about it
oh well it's a good mixture of solid
play but still it's it's a bit more
active then let's say the Queens gambit
declined which at times is a bit is a
bit stodgy this is a bit more bit more
active yeah let's see white exchange
Bishop g5 and ya hear black already has
a choice can go age 69 bd7 castle c5
number of options this was played by
Gary one of the one of the possible move
orders and now Queen c2 it's a slight
twist to III but we get an interesting
position now giro goes for g 5y a move
that is some quite clearly weakening
black skin side but also activates quite
a bit the night jumps to e4 and this has
a very direct idea if white is now not
reacting he went 92 which is something
that i would call reacting
attacking this night if he's not
reacting let's say and goes III then
blacks idea comes into play h5 yeah
crude but effective threatening h4 with
the bishop trap yeah if why does now
again not paying attention to anything
he's going to simply get his Bishop
trapped motif to to pay attention to if
you allow that as white you are really
almost yeah you're in trouble you have
to be very very precise now to not get
into into huge difficulties quite often
wide fields obliged to play the h1 which
but obviously is terrible from a
structural point of view this is this is
really a really garbage position for
white so white has to be alert and he
played night to d2 yeah it's a also all
we're known if you see the clock times
it was nothing that was new to both
players so black now takes the bishop
and goes for Knight b6 and c6 so we have
a card spot exchange Queens gambit
exchange structure this typical
structure but the twist is black has got
the bishop here but he has weakened
himself quite a bit with this formation
on the King side so it's not so obvious
how black is going to let's say place
the skin sometimes he cancels long even
the most important thing about this h6
g5 thing is that f5 is very much week
but f5 at the moment can only be
occupied by why the bishop and this is
not so terrible and would be much more
of a problem if Y term would be able to
get a night there but this is not easy
OG 3 for example which could be a place
for Nadia's upon and so this is a finely
balanced position Bishop f8 is
interesting Black is toying with the
idea to maybe fianchetto late fianchetto
on g7 should also show up the the
kingside quite a bit ok before a5 b5 and
c5 yeah so ok well Bishop g7 might have
been an ID
yeah this now is not relevant as white
with before has initiated play very
early on on the queenside and while
black this a5 b5 c5 maneuver is some
pretty standard way to meet this
minority attack on the queenside because
Black now has the nice square on c5 and
possibly see for that the right
circumstances for its night I think this
is about balance this position I think
like it can be satisfied him when a form
yeah fixing this a three Pawn there
should be two queen of six yeah this is
to prepare short castles and this
happened now yeah White has absolutely
no attack there on the edge failure yes
only one look there and you cannot
double or castle long or whatever it's
very difficult to imagine so why--just
castle short and we have now a strategic
battle where why just arguing that d5
might be a bit weak no but black has
passed good protection there that d5
might be a bit weak also f5 might be a
bit weaker so there are some some
weaknesses that that white can point
point that on the other hand black has
two bishops and the text the a
three-point all of the time I think that
this is a very young well played logical
game which is in the balance all the
time Queen do you want interesting and
looking at this possibly weakish porn
and trying to maybe play Bishop g4
trading off light squared Bishop 25 is a
good centralizing move and now Bishop b3
I had expected Bishop g4 when I saw this
Queen d1 youth but it turns out that if
we look at this let the trade on e2 on
trade of the e2 Bishop also has weakened
to the sea foursquare quite a bit and
all of a sudden blacks night is invading
there and is really looking at this week
porn a three
is surprisingly awkward for what I mean
white can play something like Knight to
f5 and yeah kind of yeah looking yeah
looking threatening hit away but it's
nothing's going on at black can play
that's a queen f6 to show up age six and
possibly this move in the mix white
really has nothing here he has to be
quite cautious that is not using the a3
pawn so Bishop g4 didn't lead to
anything yeah Bishop to d3 then Bishop
d7 Bishop c2 we are widest trying to
grab the a4 pond and he managed to do
that but this is not nothing special you
see with this series of trades look at
to capture Quinn takes ok form black
gets this pawn back and this now is a
really static poor information where
white can only try to play with this
Queen d3 idea you're trying to invade
their on h7 this is why black giri is
going for a 3 blocking the third-ranked
or controlling the third-ranked so that
23 is not on and this basically
rockslide of any any ambitious plan it's
quite clear that with such active pieces
here black can never be vers you know
but it's also difficult for him to do to
do anything as White's structure is also
very very sound so we got this this
trade and this tradin and right here I
briefly thought oh wait maybe white can
do something I have Queen at night um
against the somewhat weakened King
position Queen Anne Ida a notoriously
dangerous attacking duel but the problem
is that in this particular situation the
black be porn is providing very serious
counter play and there's also the issue
that the white knight while looking nice
only form is not very stable you don't
have a very stable square for it white
also doesn't
doesn't manage if we look at this
Queenie 5 and it's directly attacked
white also does not manage to to get to
a situation where he can maybe like
reroute the night and G 493 night f5
this kind of thing it would be nice but
well it takes time one move to move
three moves and all of a sudden be five
B 4 B 3 and it gets very scary for white
so if you shuffle around or move around
on the kingside you might just get
killed by the people on the logical
result really of all this is that blacks
bad King position is ultimately leading
to something which is perpetual or like
here a total equality yeah I think this
was a very logical and pretty much yeah
understandable game how it how it went
and it shows that it's that this opening
is some is really quite interesting you
know black never got into into into any
any trouble and he got the bishop pair
early on and situation like that is
really am quite interesting to play I
know it turned out to be a draw and but
this is not a very solemn not a doll
position and there are still ideas and
things to try if the other side is
making making mistakes okay next game is
mummy dr off Mammadov pretty similar
names have to be cautious now let's get
going where's this game let me load it
ok and we got some ice laughs mammadov
play in the semis love not not not one
of his regular openings yeah but it
seems that he really has prepared stuff
for this event in particular he's um
king's indian guy normally i have played
king's indian with white against his
Kings Indian in blitz games I think not
sure that they are on the channel but
he's got a long history of playing on
the ICC so um it's a bit bit term
unusual to see that from him yeah we
have I have to admit that of this
opening we have the entire Moscow this
is the Moscow variation of the Semite
slave and Bishop edge fries the entire
Moscow that this is a line that I never
really studied or even vaguely
understood so it's a bit difficult for
me to to give any any substantial advice
on this um the line basically starts
here with the parting of the ways this
is what I know Bishop b2 is by far the
main move but white has tried other
things age for Queens it to and so on
the general outline of this line is dead
white with bishop age form has initiated
a pawn sacrifice why does am a clean
clean is a pawn down not getting it back
quickly but on the other hand black
needed to play both g5 and b5 and yeah
this is a long-standing or along no one
drifting in chess if you combine b5 and
g5 it will be difficult to get a save
King position so black OS has this this
issue with his King long term but it's
upon and one thing in particular to
mention is that as long as there is this
construction here the white Bishop is
also not very active piece all this was
this was all the rage let's say I'm in
the in the late late 2000s yeah 2008
match between Kramnik and honored for
example feature that for I mean both
players played it with with it but with
switching colors I'm ready to spin not
as popular recently but not I'm not
informed about the the theory here there
should be two as normal this is what I
know and I'd be g7 yeah black blacks
mean movers Bishop d7 I think but this
also has been tried the big difference
of the between two moves us that with
nad bd7 white is now able to play d 5
which is not possible after Bishop e7
yeah it gets very very sharp now ctx he
takes 95 yeah all kinds of stuff is
hanging b5 is hanging um black is
attacking the d5 pawn now and what does
he play it doesn't really look at those
I mean what about this and I'd be five
let's just briefly check yeah okay Black
is the check and probably will take all
is the night I don't know yeah it's
super technical but I couldn't really
catch up with the theoretical
developments here of recent years so i'm
just i'm going to say that what the next
move here mahmoud jaros next move but
should be five is a novelty at least
according to my on pretty big database
um and well it's fairly logical yeah we
you get on this diagonal here pinning
the the night and it's not so easy for
black to to play now to be perfectly
honest Black is in trouble really
quickly in this game um and without them
investing hours on trying to understand
what was happening here and from the
theoretical point of view I cannot
really tell whether where the problems
begin um I totally dislike blacks
position is what I have to say so it's a
bit difficult for me I looked at this
opening the semi sloth quite a bit but I
never really liked this this line for
black because you never have a safe King
which is kind of problem for me and also
here I totally dislike black blacks
position but it's probably not not that
bad objectively speaking the comp
already gives white an advantage here
but we're talking about a position that
has been played quite a bit but should
be five is is new as mentioned but it's
not a total backwater or theorem yeah
black played Bishop g7 this this is kind
of kind of normal looking what else is
there so look looks very logical and now
Queen D for this is one problem you know
why just developing here with a tempo
centralizing the Queen and black doesn't
have much choice yeah 93 check that's
cuz
here when txtx castles and now well
white is just far better developed yes
the better structure for just one pawn
and what about blacks King positioning
and it all looks like a mess so keep he
cancelled and Mammadyarov went 94 yeah
it is also quite quite the obvious move
trying to increase the pressure there on
the diagonal um yeah and and now I think
the next move um gets black into really
substantial trouble um I think it
already is in some trouble but he now to
Connie for and that doesn't seem to be
working at all um I can tell you what
the computer suggests and it looks sick
if you tell wants to play in the night
and allow this this just to happen which
is which looks horrible for a human
being right allowing the night day on f6
and if you just magically transfer
widescreen to h6 is checkmate or Brooke
for that matter which okay seems even
more fairy tale-like but well it's close
to checkmate rights the black king is
it's looking very strange and what white
is also better here in this position but
at least the comp says it's better than
what he did and this is probably
probably true but because what he did is
leading to to disaster relief Bishop g7
yeah and now what is it that you that
you but she that you should play the
rookies hanging and the question is
really should you already give up the
exchanges black he played a five trying
to keep the exchange problem is if you
move rupee eight the simplest looking
option then white is just grabbing here
and threatens made there on g7 and black
has no defense that is in any way
satisfactory can play this yeah like but
this is a disaster and white is much
much better here you get the pawn there
and where your pawn up and you're just
much much better anyway yeah this
position would be rather pawn probably
and your your pawn up on top of it
so well black had to go for something
like that 'if I've Bishop takes that was
the idea yeah if Queen takes rupee eight
is surprisingly surprisingly unclear
yeah that's in fact this kind of idea is
still about playable it's not looking
great but it's playable this is much
better though just taking it upon and
now we see the big problems there the
night Hanks black has no King position
d3 hangs yeah he went to Bishop f5
that's relatively best smooth and yeah
now mama yar of plays rook a to e 1
which is from its appearance a bit
mysterious it's better be hotness it
looks far more natural to play rook
everyone but that was rejected um not
they're not totally sure why it looks
like um the more natural move to me and
while the engine does confirm that black
is in big trouble why does just
threatening rook takes e4 as simple as
that and what exactly is black going to
do one way to try to defend this book c8
the idea said Ruby for can be answered
by oopsie form nice trick but after you
create what can just take the pawn we
see a similar scenario in the game but
black white playbook 81 and with the
rook on f1 with rooks here black has 93
with a discovered attack on the rook
sorry for this groupon f1 and well this
is not possible here I mean okay like
and play the move but i'm just taking
here and going to ask you what exactly
it's your night doing um so it's it's
it's a fairly simple business rook
everyone just rinse the game after that
black is is busted he has no way no way
out of no way out of that look AE 1 i'm
also seems to be very good for what but
it's not it's probably not as s decisive
simply due to the fact that now rook c8
is still a move yeah here taking 93 is
at least netting black this is rook
there so um he will have um he will be
in exchange up for two points even that
looks quite good for white but well
relatively speaking why Dwight has
better option he is still better he
played b3 to cover them the sea for the
c-4 square as rook c4 was was in the in
the mix yeah here black went g-form this
this also seems to give Y to the chance
to win the game right away um Knight c3
is what the engine gives us better and
this is heavily engine produced because
the position is so I'm so forced you can
really rely on the computer quite a bit
down Bishop g7 is what white can try
attacking the rook and h6 and this
initiates a very long sequence this is
quite funny check-check has to take ya
note how unlucky this this rook
placement was um rookie one rookie eight
saving the look for the mode wish of age
6 + f6 quite funny black is trying to
trap the bishop but white has d6 as a
move and after King h7 there's really
funny sequence 95 check King g6g form
yeah good luck in calculating that over
the world but i just want to show a
prime example of computer computer
variation d7 all of a sudden yeah what
gets us back can't some somewhere around
here he will also regained the e to pawn
which leaves white a porn up and quite
substantially better still yeah
interesting line but this whole line is
of course far to DP atlases 12 moves
just to illustrate what was possible but
it seems 93 was a tougher move
after g4 mamedyarov went bishop age 8
and while this looks very promising it
seems that the alternative move rook
takes e4 was very much in whites favor
here black cannot take the night to
start with that due to Bishop f6
followed by rubgy for this leads to
again to a disaster and Queen B 6 check
important intermediate check Bishop g6
if black takes check it's made on g7 so
Bishop 26 and now why can take and d6 is
going to be promotion for the deep on
with a wide win as he has the d pawn
under control yeah so loopy for its
bishop before yeah that's then that's a
tougher move but then Queen takes G
takes f3 Queen f3 leads to a very very
nice position for white you're
threatening Bishop f6 now and then the
check here are here according to
circumstances with made on g7 so black
it really has to play f5 which is well
not great for the King position 2327
let's say I'm t6 this type of position
this is really horrible for black white
has two points a fantastic dominating
bishop only five and the d6 bond that's
terrible I mean he can hang on but why
this is really substantially better than
this position um so lucky for was was
was very strong I think that this is not
something I mean number jar of saw that
this rookie for is a good movie probably
did miscalculate something with them
Bishop h8 that made him believe that
this is even better I mean the the
upcoming sequence now is really wacky
but it is a vision for black quite funny
enough f6 yeah cutting cutting this
bishop and now night h5 that was the
idea an idea to I'm sorry and now black
has
play d2 lets the only move that does the
trick if black is retreating rookie for
is again very very strong yeah as we see
after ticks ticks white is coming with
this and this is in fantastic shape yeah
d to had to be played rook takes e4 now
that probably was what's the plan takes
takes and now queen d seven saves the
day funny enough this is looking at
those squares using the Queen as a
defender and white still has to worry
about this D to bond yeah it seems that
all this is pretty much forced quite
remarkably Queen D for looking at the
pawn yeah trying to get it back Roxy 122
cake sticks and now Queen h7 remarkably
at the bishop is still alive there but
now the queen is here a very important
spot covering in crucial squares and
getting this counter play at the end
it's it's a draw it's really funny yeah
it's a draw bye-bye this checking
mechanism John White has no way out of
that I mean what policy is supposed to
try like this check um ok King takes but
black can do something like that trying
to check it with the rook and you are
arguably playing for last year's what
yeah that was a really wacky game very
strange game it seems that mamedyarov
had a couple of chances to to try to win
and all this year is very complicated
but I don't want to get too deep into
that as we have other games to cover
that were arguably more important for
the overall standings of the tournament
on also interesting yeah White had some
chances there but when he did not take
them Mammadov put up a good um
calculational effort to to save the game
okay so next two games that's not need
to be what am I doing here I'm doing
reversed alphabetical right so let me
not screw it up his car
wanna next koala and Kalin is pretty
close okay Kara wanna with white plane
Wesley so my notes yeah I know it's okay
let's get going we have d4 caruana is
really sticking with that in this
tournament at the NIMS oh and Knight f3
y an idea three is some very flexible
choice where Black now has a couple of
answers for example he also has this
option going back to the rosin I'm not
sure if so what's playing that I think I
think it does they all played but this
time b6 was played yeah mixing the
Queen's Indian with the names of one of
the main replies my personal preference
here at c5 as I like to play the
positions after G 396 they are playing
against you three are always enjoyed and
this is what mostly happens the
alternative for wide is a 3m the main
alternative to g3 which leads to a
rubenstein where black is totally ok
just the mainland though it's not that
white is giving up anything yeah well be
6 um here why it has two or three main
choices the the main move probably is
Bishop defy this is what Kasparov played
a lot in the 80s and 90s and this is
also what what led to this line
sometimes being called the coast para
variation this is also quite sharp yeah
black often pushes the bishop away like
this jumps to you for quite sharp but
white also has to move III this is one
of those moves that that from first
appearance look passive but they are not
but it is not the reason is that if we
look at this bishop also inside with 94
I'm sorry I wasn't sure if it should be
seven or 94 played what white is doing
here he's just delaying the fight a
little bit he fights for the e4 square
and by putting this early pressure on e4
and black had to do something like 94 if
he's sitting still white plays he find
a great center so it's pretty clear that
we get to this structure here with black
playing f5 so have a look at this this
is in fact something that is not at all
passive for wide with e3 what white is
trying to do long-term this move this
night from f3 I think did you start with
that I'm not sure about the move on and
no we played c5 but you can also move
the night away from from f3 what white
often does is move the night away to one
of those squares play f3 pushing the
night back and then try 44 getting a big
center later or white has a second
option and this is something that it's
now played by cora wanna see 5 very
interesting and it's not that's not a
very popular move but but i think quite
quite enterprising um what happens if
black takes upon he didn't yeah this was
played by it so taking on c5 yeah it's
it's a move it has been played by a vcr
hunt for example rook be one Queen CA
this was a game which you golf ireland
from 2013 Bishop e3 this is why it's
idea yeah he gives up the c5 point for
the moment and blackwell at some point
maybe even being able to take on deform
if the rook has moved I think this is
what Anna did right yeah he played rupee
n can put that on the board rook e8 and
now white actually did take on c5 which
is not strictly necessary but why do is
see five tries to open up the position
quickly for the bishop here and for play
on the queenside one reason is that if
you go back and look at this position a
white is playing very slowly and not
doing much I mean sometimes people play
relatively harmless stuff like this
let's say it's not a very sensible move
but what black often gets is this kind
of attacking idea look to g6 and eyeing
at this this is a very dangerous
attacking idea so why it should be quick
you shouldn't waste time and this is a
move that definitely does not waste time
was very interesting idea
ruge f6 though was played and I'm not
totally sure about this idea it looks
some ambitious but not sure that it
leads to much why display is really
quickly with night you wanted now with
yeah Ruby one Quincy eight and then
three this is what I'm what I'm talking
about with the Rue k f6 really has this
idea to play Luke g6 and attack on the
long diagonal but it never materializes
why this is far too quick in the center
here we have 95 and now Bishop b2 yeah
note that white is not interested in
capturing on c5 I mean it's not totally
terrible to do that but he's just
arguing that ok I don't want equality
material wise with a somewhat rotten
porn structure I rather have you to take
on d4 this is happening now being a pawn
down but having really really nice um
positions for the pieces now that
there's a default porn instead of to see
pawns for example the idea night deep
sorry and mouse is acting up the idea
night d3 to c5 comes into into the into
the play and this is exactly what
happens I really like White's position
yeah i think it's a it's quite awkward
for black to play it's probably not bad
for black in the true sense of the word
but it's difficult to play it's not it's
not easy to handle because you also have
two pieces the night in the rook that
has somewhat misplaced you rather have
them back on ave dan don't have six
maybe let's say yeah bishop a6 that that
makes sense the bishop wasn't doing
anything there we should be to angling
for that and here we come the bishop is
activated
yeah why does a pawn down but he has a
very active position note that this
Bishop here won't be too and we let's
see that also after the trades you can
put this on the board the bishop on b2
is really really strong compared to the
night the night on e 7 has one big issue
it doesn't have a stable outpost square
where it can go to where I can just sit
and yeah being protected and fulfilling
some kind of useful role it's a it's
really not having a good a good place a
good place to go to rookie 6 was played
queen d 3 yeah and now it's possible
that around here so it's um it's getting
into trouble it's not so not so easy to
determine the precise moment where he
starts to struggle on the computer here
wants to go rook piayed yeah priority
I'm doing this first I cannot pronounce
that word look p 8 yeah um the idea is
that well after here this is a move that
certainly makes you think about rupee 8
that the computer just very
cold-bloodedly wants to play rook f6 the
idea being that well that you're not
ignoring the fact that this is in the
industry agonal and yeah this makes a
little bit awkward to play for for a
human but there seems to be no
particular problem the computer just
says equal it doesn't see anything
terrible happening I still think that
white has a pretty nice position but it
seems to be without any particular
short-term drawback what happened in the
game whatever was problematic he went
night to g6 and after g3 which was quite
apparent I guess as a reply it's
difficult to keep the pawn down so he
probably had intended to give the porn
back but it really leads to a
problematic situation now played rugby 8
and queen here would be 6
should before yeah now we have those
trades they're so books are traded maybe
a um so was just thinking along the
lights that that those trade trades
might help him in the in the defense but
this is really a surprisingly difficult
position for black he has to protected
sorry two connected passed pawns C&D
porn but it doesn't really help him
simply because the white Bishop is so
much stronger than the night and this is
a related related feature white also has
chances to attack black skin black skin
as those pawns I on the queenside is
only protected by two pawns and white
has this double / information but this
is something that can be quite helpful
like you can push the f porn as an
attacking unit let's say without
compromising your pond shield of the
king so why this white is quite
substantially better here also there's a
very concrete problem a seven eggs yeah
this is why c5 was played but note that
after the check here black is in is in
trouble he went c4 which makes the pawns
completely immobile so not a desirable
move but what what what is it that he
should have done if you look at this
King here oops with a double attack very
awkward or king evade the same business
he had to do this and well this is very
awkward now the pawns are not yeah not
marching forward anymore and why it has
all the ideas yeah attacking the king
and dominating with his pieces yeah why
did is much much better here and there
were one or two cases where you can
argue that maybe kerwin I could have
played even more powerful for example
here there's nothing in particular to
say against bishop a7 just taking the
pawn but
well he just kept kept the pressure on
did not take take any a bounty yet let's
say Jack and why is getting this pawn
and still has some this is this huge
advantage of the bad black king
Hereafter Queen f7 at least black
managed to trade Queens and this however
is an endgame that is very very
favorable for white and probably also
quite quite close to winning I did not
look at this in a very no not for a very
long time to really figure out if it's
just clearly better for while winning I
think it should be a win the problem is
that if we look at this here this has
happening quite quite quite logically
this kind of structure white is blocking
the two pawns and he has this age for
age five business it's a dollar pawn I
know but yeah H pawn the peering
combined with the long-range Bishop all
the way to the promotion square is
usually too much for the night
especially considering that white is
always ready to let's under this always
ready to march up and pick up ons when
the H pawn will be a distraction for
King at night yeah we had a check pretty
quick finish of this chances a nice
little intermezzo and those split pawns
are how more dangerous than the
connected pawns I think when did he
resign Yeah right here the age porn is
just is just promoting or let's say this
move is coming up both them both this
decisive so a good winner for Kawana
he's some scoring his second win in a
row after beating Kramnik the wrong
before while West days so lost on his
second game of the event he lost against
Anand and now he lost against Caruana so
he is a he has much difficulty with the
word soul and talking about
gameplay and then so well it means that
he's now back to a plus one score still
not bad at all for one of his first
super tournaments but he had this
brilliant start with three and a half
out of four so a little bit
disappointing for sure for him 2 2 to
lose his second game but a very good
game by baka wanna okay next game is
then let's go to that one of the modern
classics let's say Kramnik playing black
kia against Magnus card so we have world
champion 14 against world champion
number 16 let's get going evo okay so we
get the golden no surprise very young
much expected okay 93 as cars usually
plays I'm always surprised that he
prefers that move because is such a
great end game player but it seems that
in the Berlin endgame he also feels that
white is not getting getting anywhere
okay Bishop c5 which we just have to say
that he also scores excellently with d3
but yeah I always think that well if you
are great in the end game you probably
should try to to grind out something out
of the Berlin endgame but this is not
doing that so often okay castles castles
yeah a little side note is that white
can absolutely not grab and pawns here
this kind of thing is actually quite
favorable for black Avenger blacks
development is very strong white cannot
snatch all those pawns Queenie ADA's
giving huge counterplay alright huge
counterplay I'm leg is better right
counterplay implies that white has some
play what he did is just yeah getting
himself into trouble so just castles now
I have a black has to attend to the pond
d6h three yeah not a move that cousin I
think this is new to Carlson the cards
in some practice but it's a known move
and Kramnik now place 97 this is
one of the recent developments of let's
say last two or three years to play this
very early on in the Berlin try to get
the night to g6 play c6 and try to
equalize completely their only way for
white forward against that is in many
ways d 4 and this is what cards and
played d for Bishop p6 this is the idea
like it's not giving up on the center
right away his ideas that after d takes
a five Black has both night XD for as a
possibility just regaining the pawn
immediately but it can also whoops that
was the wrong person I'm sorry for that
d 4 GX takes you can also recapture
that's awesome d take see five because
if I was also hanging of course this was
played in a game by Sheila graph pins
Peter Leko in Beijing last year so we
are dealing with a known position let's
see Carson went Bishop d3 or ever yeah
quite logical maintaining the centro
tension and chrome neck goes with d5 a
very direct way to play trying to
clarify the central situation yeah what
shouldn't do that blundering a piece de
594 and also looks really nice for black
I think got the knight to e5 to e4 I'm
sorry yeah possible Bishop f5 96 sorry
yeah I have to get a new mouse yeah
that's not really traveling black 92
looks looks tougher and it was quickly
played back calls takes takes takes
takes each XD for by chronic and now
Quincy to quickly plate not the most
intuitive of moves and the quick speed
and this was played suggest that that's
all preparation yeah Carlton has played
two World Championship matches in last
two years against Russia a lot and I'm
not
well not guessing there but huge portion
of the prep for that matches will
probably be have been about the Berlin
and you never know it probably has a
couple of ideas install that never yeah
that hath not been played yet yeah the
same probably applies for chrome nagar
but in this case cows and gets the the
move in first what is the idea but broad
quincy too well very simple one at first
it looks at the pawn their on h7 and
also white quickly tries to get in the
rook to d1 trying to say that okay it's
pretty symmetrical um I understand but
if I am quicker with my rook your queen
might get a bit uncomfortable in the
center cronic played age six yeah that
is certainly right we don't want Y to
take on 87 and g6 is rubbish so h6 looks
fine and now a form was played again
quickly played yeah introducing the idea
to play a five quite obviously yeah now
kramnik played c6 still playing
relatively quickly the capture on c3 is
a move that white probably I get
analized it anyway but it's something
that also why probably would have
welcomed I couldn't really refute the
move in my in my um my analysis here but
it looks very dangerous black has to
play the very unnatural move Queen yet
and now a five or Queens is really all
net very nice compensation for what I
couldn't find a win but the wind or
something very very strong for what but
this is the kind of move you really want
to avoid if if your opponent is blitzing
out stuff and clearly knows what he's
doing you rather want to play safe and
sound moves and not grab every pawn that
sets offered to you c6 is also
objectively perfectly fine c 6-r ook t1
going on this d file and now night d phi
yes still played quite quite quickly but
chronic he was not thinking into deep
thought though we have to by the way
keep in mind that chronic lost the last
two games yeah he lost his game against
mamedyarov and then against kawana so
certainly is not in them yeah and then
the best psychological state probably
95-94 or normal and rookie ate all this
looks fairly logical a five now very
interesting why does just pushing the a
pond and asking black okay what is this
can you take the pot yeah black took the
pond and the correctly so you can take
the pond and noun idea three still part
of the preparation and ocala spent ten
minutes here is quite often quite often
they say I this guy and it's not knowing
any Theory that's not true he just
doesn't go to two main main path all of
the time he has his ideas but he mixes
it words with some unconventional
openings here and there and frankly
sometimes I think you forget stuff if
I'm so I mean what what was this game
one against an odd but what I'm what I'm
trying to say is that it is a mixed bag
sometimes you really don't know what
cars is doing in the opening and you ask
yourself did he really study this
opening but he has his novelties and
ideas and this is one of them yeah he
played this quickly and now it's scrum
Nick to solve this over the board and
it's not easy at all why does
threatening the c-4 move here this is
not a very intuitive plan a five and
then back yeah also see forced idea and
why did he jettison the apron in the
first place because here the Queen also
has to keep an eye on this bishop so
without a five being inserted let's say
black could probably just move the Queen
somewhere which is not possible yes the
bishop bangs and well chronic defended
well he played b5 the let's say
mechanical way to prevent
see for now 94 was played attacking the
weakness that was created by the b5
month yeah now we come to a pretty
mysterious situation because now chronic
went Bishop c7 after very long thought
and it's quite strange he said sorry i
read i read that he said in the press
conference that he was miscalculating
things him on more than one occasion and
looking at at this move the system they
are very believable the thing is that if
he would have played on Bishop b7 now
the game would have been really really
balanced white doesn't have anything
better than taking on b5 and grabbing
this pawn back and here black has no
problem whatsoever you can play let's
say a 6 and Bishop Bishop here for this
idea or you can also just drop this back
and place the bishop on his or one of
his best diagonals black has the bishop
pair to compensate for the slight
weakness of the IQ PIAA on d5 this is
quite clearly okay for black and the
problem is probably not that Kramnik
didn't see that he certainly saw that
but he thought that Bishop c7 is
probably more ambitious or more
interesting move and he went for that um
and it seems some quadrant II that the
move is not working it is some it is
very complicated from a technical point
of view but it seems that it's simply
not working yeah Carla took this pawn
yeah 16 Queen t6 that much was clear and
now g6 sg3 I'm sorry yeah Queen edge to
was was the point yeah now we see the
the problems there there's quite a lot
of stuff hanging if black well black
cannot move the night let's start like
that it's in the pin if you take here
Bishop
five is hitting but the night is hanging
what exactly are you playing he went
Bishop d7 that was was planned Bishop to
f4 that's very strong and Queen c6 now
was played after some hesitation it
seems that one of the things that
kramnik did not evaluate correct it was
the move Queen d7 here and this is this
apparently was pointed out by Carlton in
the press conference so he had seen this
this can be answered by the very strong
move c4 that's really a nice move yeah
attacking the pawn attacking with the
pawn and something like let's say Bishop
takes cb5 is excellent for white those
lines are not so easy to see now this is
protected and you still get the night
back the very nice position for wide
after c4 blackest is pretty much busted
yeah he can he can try this this this
but after Queen c4 why does again very
much very much better you know it's just
a case where black is really badly
coordinated let's say something like
this yeah and now Luke p8 not be seven
days straight away losing yeah black
isn't in trouble really big trouble him
and chronic probably miscalculates
something here I think I think this is
what he said he was intending intended
to play Queen to d7 yeah which is funny
move in its own right yeah I mean this
is in fact quite quite ok 44 black it's
very very tricky all of that but it
didn't it didn't work due to see form
yeah ultimately he decided to play this
and after Bishop takes him um yeah he
basically has to sacrifice now yeah if
he goes let's say he plays Queen here
then this is the problem yeah look
covers
and this is far too much threatening
rook a7 and and so on then why does just
steamrolling him very nice it's quite
interesting how quickly blacks position
is going down it tries to be one check
funny tactic of course not this now as
Queen d5 gets really ugly for what you
can just about save the game of Queenie
forward of course King edge to as the
move we are keeping this intact after
look sorry after luke t one Bishop c6
white is winning far too much material
so he gave the Queen with Queen takes d5
rook takes rook takes Andrew q1 yeah
very important trading off this this
active piece there's no alternative here
yeah and now the the problem is that
well from a material point of view this
is not enough yeah there's bishop and
rook against the Queen um and the second
thing is black is not very well
coordinated yeah his pieces is bishops
they don't have stable squares and why
this at the moment it looks like the
queen is back home on the one but it is
actually quite active it can jump to d5
the right moment or gets activated on
the King side we see that happening
quite quickly here with this move after
this I'm sorry if black takes here for
example now queen bee five is a very
strong intermediate move now the queen
is just too strong here Bishop sp6 was
played and now Bishop e3 trading off one
of the bishops yeah rook to e1 try for
some kind of counter play the problem is
that you cannot even keep the apron if
you do this Queenie 72 even losing more
stuff yeah that sometimes you can really
fight with rook and Bishop against Queen
if you have a
some some kind of fortress let's say if
you imagine just for a moment let's say
white spawn would be on before yeah and
the bishop on c4 where it protects b5
they protect each other it protects f7
this would be quite reasonable to trying
to trying to draw but here why does not
have any problems in exposing them then
the problems in blacks camp it's just
not coordinated well gee for not getting
checkmated on h1 and now white is
invading yeah this is a very simple
technical task for someone like cards on
here I can't push the whole position
let's forward step by step check we need
to look at this much detail it's funny
that the White King is playing a role
here in the attack the only neat little
thing to mention is this f5 takes and
now Queen g3 and g5 that's quite neat
yeah the f5 point is used as a shield
that White's king is safe and here white
is winning with a checkmating attack
Queen h4 h 6 g7 it's the mating pattern
that I cannot really prevent so when
very nice we near 44 Carlton this time
based on good preparation it didn't lead
to an objective advantage as we see from
the line Bishop g7 instead of Bishop to
c7 but it seems that Kramnik was
irritated and yeah well it's a case
where after losing two games probably
you're not in a super great state of
mind yeah this is the the first time it
seems that Kramnik lost three games in a
row in classical tournament chess at
least nobody could come up with a with a
comparative result comparable result in
the past he probably lost three in blitz
or rapid or something like that but in
classical chess sets unheard of yeah he
really am he
he started well with with a nice early
early win in the in the first round but
now three losses in a row places him
near the bottom of the tournament table
yeah enter yesterday we learned that on
Kramnik declined the invitation to play
in the in the new started a tournament
series what is this called the Grand
Tour something i don't have the the term
right I think this tournament series
consisting of Norway chests the sink
real cop and the London chess classics
he declined the invitation to play this
series which hmm seems some bit puzzling
to me maybe he really intends to retire
at age 40 se as he said and he turns 40
in June I think this year or in the
summer let's say um ok we will see okay
so only one game left and this is vishy
anand its micky adams the to a player
syria on mount adams and wishes got
white what is he playing c4 aha so he
played efore earlier not his d for that
he was so successful with in recent
events and now he plays c4 yeah
versatility is so important in modern
chess we get a very unexpected opening
actually 5 g 36 and now this goes for
Knight f3 very interesting and this this
has gained a little bit of popularity
this way of playing um in general white
tried in recent yes to play d4 against
this line but it seems that this has
gotten a bit out of fashion I'm not
quite sure why yeah white always seem to
squawk wide well maybe it is due to e4
I'm not sure well neither 3 is
interesting as we she played but it's
not it's not a very common move
attacking e5 and pushes 924 and now this
was played by Adams this is the
prescribed method against this but
recently white as it seems as I found a
couple of games they are of this of this
line White has gained some ground there
um interesting now 92 c 2 and 93 with a
tempo queen age five and now 93 yeah
it's a it's a very unconventional type
of position but interesting why tries to
attack the e4 pawn this exposed porn
while black tries to prove that his
gained space he gained quite some space
there that has gained spaces was worth
something as well and probably this is
about balance but it is an interesting
tense situation Bishop c5 was played and
after Queen see to Adams took on III
yeah quite quite an unconventional
decision but he wants to simply get rid
of this night now to being able to cover
his afore porn yeah this stronghold porn
is something that white that wyd wants
to attack and black wants to wants to
keep um it's interesting this is
actually a known position but certainly
both players I think they they they were
just playing over the border I found a
sample game here and correspondence game
actually wear a white player went for
before now in this situation which does
seem quite logical yeah why not before
but grown arnaud is going for p3 why not
yeah you have to fianchetto anyway and
it's questionable if you really want to
put it out two squares yeah and losing
your structure and I think that here
here now Adams went Queen to e6 that's
some an interesting moment here because
after Queen e6
I can show you what what we she did for
us after Queenie six now Anand took a
very very interesting decision but in
decision that form yeah when you see the
resulting position you probably will
agree that this is a pretty pretty clear
case where white has compensation he
took on the f5 he just sacrificed this
is exchange and got the poor now so let
let us head up White has to excellently
placed bishops there he's got a big pond
center it's far back but it is due to
the state of being far back it's also
very flexible yeah white can can can
really choose what setup he likes like
d3 d4 later d44 for the full center or
keeping them back for the moment he also
has the F file for the other loop to
join and cap there that is pretty clear
compensation it's a question though if
Adams should have prevented it he could
have prevented it if he plays Bishop g6
now I know it looks a bit tricky to stay
in this diagonal here in this diagonal
but there's no no real problem with that
he could have started with Bishop g6 and
then play Queen e6 back to avoid this
the question is what is really needed
that to avoid this i'm not sure i don't
think that white is really more than the
exchange or more than enough
compensation for the exchange but what
I'm pretty confident about is that this
position is simpler to play for white
this much is very much this is clear and
the next thing is also a bit a bit
debate over what he does now he played
Queen g6 and jam I was thinking getting
out of this might be interesting getting
like a queen e6 something like that is a
pretty logical line that this might be
interesting in the game you got double
pawns on the F file and I thought maybe
this is better but well look at this
it has a good compensation here so very
nicely played by are not getting an
imbalance in the game and this is the
first start of the first step with
trying to play for when you need to get
some kind of imbalance now interesting
yeah this was played though and after
this now it gets difficult to black to
avoid the double porn on the FR rook
here and this was played check and e4
that's interesting it looks like white
is putting his own bishop passive but
that's not the case the bishop can
always be activated later by bishop h3
at the right moment but why does its he
sets up this stable porn center that
also limits blacks rooks considerably
blacks rooks have no black the black
looks easier to pronounce and have no no
direct targets yeah those pawns I mean
as safe as they they come you're
absolutely protected it's difficult to
black to find any any direct counter
play however it doesn't seem like it
should be terrible for him it's it's
difficult to play though it's really
difficult to play and there are one or
two spots where I wasn't really sure if
this is this is the right one i'm going
to show you one or two key moments yeah
white white has time and yet improved a
little bit here and now adams place the
most age five at first this looks like a
blunder yeah rook f5 why is he
blundering this pawn I mean of course he
did not I really don't think he
overlooked who get fire that's quite
quite clear but um he wanted to give up
this pawn for a counter play that he
gets he gets play but the question is if
it is enough um yeah black did not need
to do that he also could have played I
don't know just sit there
seven or whatever and ask why to to to
do something White has ideas though yeah
Bishop to a five for example Quincy one
rakesh for ya all this is coming
naturally too wide it's much easier for
y to play however if you give it to a
computer it doesn't see anything great
for white happening in the next in the
foreseeable future so it's it's a
debatable decision if you want to really
give away the pawn or not he sacrificed
this and receiver she took the point
this was the idea he wanted to invade
with the Queen and start this counter
play that's a very human decision yeah
why not you want you want some play on
your own or for yourself but the thing
is it doesn't seem to lead to much black
gets get this in but what now yeah the
white queen and rook are still putting
up this pressure on f6 went rogue d6
look f-105 yeah this is all ok I think
and still quite quite ok for black I
mean it's not lost here look the 883
yeah the next move however is probably
oh let's say around here there is there
is there's a problem I mean instead of
before I probably should have tried
something else Queen D for maybe this
has a tactical problem I mean this is
the problem
Queen f6 and the real problem is not
that when the pod can be defended I know
no problem there ya like like this for
example but now white gets the Bishop to
c4 and this is a huge deal the bishop on
c4 is very nicely positioned it defends
be three it is defended by both porn cm
very stable and it looks at the crucial
f7 pawn and now Wyatt gets the play on
their file he probably should have
played instead of before some
protections done I didn't even write
down alternative there that's sloppy
yeah maybe queen t for something I mean
I prefer white with the two points what
has the better chances but I mean once
this is in I think why does this is much
much much much better yeah and close I
don't think you can can defend this
position so it looks very tricky here
and now the White Queen starts his
invasion White has time he has all the
play black and just said and we have
attacking ideas with g5 and look how
strong this Bishop is that's a the
important deal yeah F takes G takes f6
is also the threat so Adams didn't see
anything better than that check but here
the H porn is the decisive factor still
blacks rooks are not coordinated well
yet only lasted a couple of moves and
here Adams resigned yeah why in
particular and let's have a look carrick
check
my mouth well there is the rook doing
going down yeah so this was around vishy
anand with another win so he's now
trailing the world champion cards and of
course at the moment with the terrific
scorers got a plus for school and i'm
not mistaken um getting to a 3000
performance magic 3000 and this she is
having a great tournament as well with a
plus two very very nice very nice some
performance um yeah clearly showing that
he is still in competition for for being
a serious challenger to the world
champion after those two matches okay
great i hope you've enjoyed the coverage
here of the round seven I'll be back for
round eight and nine of course though I
have to warn you that probably around
nine will come a little bit late only on
Monday I guess as I have a very
important game myself on Sunday okay
well thanks for watching